we talk about all the time when we're  doing stunts together or we're having  just such a crazy day we're like how  cool is it that we get to share this  with each other and we have our memories  documented so it's so special and i feel  an incredible amount of gratitude for  the whole experience yesterday it's me  jacob and tom we're sandwiching tom as  we're swinging from a scaffolding that's  wednesday for us so it's very special  and i think we're all lucky to be able  to be doing it with each other because  we all care so much about each other but  also having this other extraordinary  crazy life simultaneously so i've always  connected to peter parker in that way  and i think everyone can